welcome back to cbs mornings here at 7
30. new this morning cbs news has
exclusively reviewed documents that shed
more light
on internal discussions among former
president trump's advisors about the
possible seizure of voting machines
those discussions were happening as they
publicly alleged fraud in the 2020
election
there is no evidence of that fraud had
this happened it would have been an
unprecedented use of federal power
senior investigative correspondent
catherine herridge has this story for us
catherine good morning to you this would
have been the federal government
reaching into state-run elections for
the first time in american history what
more are we learning
well tony good morning while it's not
clear from the records what role former
president trump played in these
deliberations if any the records do show
several options were considered by his
team but never executed
emails and records obtained by cbs news
suggests there were multiple versions of
draft orders that called for the seizure
of voting machines after the 2020
presidential election this draft order
dated december 17th would have empowered
the secretary of homeland security to
seize collect preserve protect retain
and analyze all machines the three-page
draft also granted the homeland security
secretary the power to immediately seek
any and all search warrants to carry out
and execute this directive
a day earlier another draft order
reviewed by cbs news looked to grant
similar powers to the defense secretary
the draft which contains one typo and no
signature line for president trump is
dated december 16th and is similar to a
record previously reported by politico
emails indicate the draft orders were
shared in mid-december among a small
group advising then president trump
including rudy giuliani former new york
city police commissioner bernie carrick
former army colonel phil waldron and
retired general and trump's former
national security adviser michael flynn
who said this at the time about the
president's options
he could immediately on his order sees
every single one of these machines
around the country on his order in one
email flynn writes fix the spelling
error in the title ensure it gets a
legal review but this is ready to go
from my standpoint carrick told cbs news
the draft orders were circulated by
waldron to members of both the giuliani
legal team and a group under attorney
sydney powell as they discussed ways to
preserve evidence both teams filed
unsuccessful litigation over what they
claimed to be election fraud
carrick said he was on a call where
giuliani asked ken cuccinelli then
acting deputy secretary of homeland
security if his department had the
authority to seize the ballot machines
according to carrick cuccinelli told
giuliani no cuccinelli did not respond
to cbs's questions
while neither of the draft orders was
implemented a member of the select
committee investigating the january 6th
riot said the discussions are concerning
this was one more
avenue that he explored issuing the
executive order that would authorize
either the department of justice or
homeland security or the department of
defense just to go out and seize a
state's election machinery obviously
there's no law providing for that
and cbs news also asked for comment from
general flynn rudy giuliani sidney
powell and phil waldron but they did not
respond tony
katherine harris for us catherine thank
you very much i mean the security of
american elections guys rest in part on
a paper trail and state-run elections
this would have been an unprecedented
reach of the federal government into
that system and it would have brought
our country into uncharted territory
right yeah no doubt and if you want more
on this you can go to our podcast you
can always get the morning's news by
subscribing to our cbs morning's on the
go podcast here are today's top stories
in less than 20 minutes that is a great
deal as gail likes to say yes